he told us in a remarkable exchange with
mr. Luo that but for the Department of
Justice policy from prohibiting
prohibiting from doing so he would have
indicted president Trump and indeed it
is clear that any other citizen of this
country who behaved as the president has
has would have been charged with
multiple crimes notably my Republican
colleagues were unable to refute a
single one of these facts so where do we
go from here we will continue to seek
testimony from key fact witnesses as
many of you know the committee has
authorized several additional subpoenas
our our work will continue into the
August recess and we will use those
subpoenas if we must we will also
continue to seek important documents
from the Department of Justice and the
White House we have made some progress
on this front there appears to be
compelling evidence of the president's
misconduct outside of the four corners
of the redacted version of the Mullah
report and we will work to uncover that
evidence as well